Do girls who go together really flow together?
Hey guys, Amy with you on DNews today talking
about one of the more common lady-myths: menstrual
synchrony, or the idea that women who spend
a lot of time together find themselves menstruating
at the same time.
Since the 1970s, there have been a few studies
to suggest that synchronized menstruation
is possible between roommates, lesbian couples,
and sexually segregated groups of women.
But there have also been studies to suggest
synchrony isn’t a real thing; roommates
who are not close friends and lesbian couples
living together for a number of years have
been found to not sync their cycles.
Some studies have split the difference to
find that women’s cycles adjust for closer
flow dates, but only by a day or two.
But more recent research says that synchrony
isn’t really what’s happening.
Two separate studies done in 2006 found that
menstrual synchrony is actually just chance.
It’s normal for a woman’s cycle to last
anywhere from 21 to 35 days with menses lasting
between five and seven days.
And variations in that cycle are common.
Many women experience erratic or even missed
periods.
So not only are regular periods actually quite
irregular, there are all kinds of things that
can impact your cycle.
Stress is a common culprit, be it personal
like a breakup, professional like losing your
job, or life stress like a moving to a new
city.
Scientists aren’t exactly sure how this
one works, but we know that stress affects
the hypothalamus gland that controls the pituitary
gland that in turn controls the ovaries (among
other things) and help manage hormones.
And hormone imbalance can lead to a change
in cycle.
We see this most commonly with medication.
Antidepressants and antipsychotics can elevate
the pituitary hormone called prolactin that
can affect the hormones responsible for regulating
your cycle.
Hormonal birth control also affects a woman’s
cycle by preventing ovulation and thickening
cervical mucus to prevent pregnancy.
But even non-hormonal birth control like copper
IUDs can disrupt a cycle just by virtue of
putting a foreign object inside the uterus.
Changes in diet and exercise can affect your
cycle as well.
Working out typically more leads to shorter,
lighter periods, but excessive exercise can
actually stop menstruation altogether.
It has to do with body fat.
Too little body fat and a woman stops ovulating.
On the opposite end of the spectrum, weight
gain can cause the ovaries to produce extra
testosterone leading to longer cycles or missed
periods.
Illness, too, though more serious illnesses
than a common cold, can affect a cycle.
It’s not unheard of for a women to bleed
while seriously ill with a virus, changing
her cycle’s start date.
But like all myths, there’s a grain of truth
to the idea that women can sync by proximity.
Pheromones are the chemical substances we
excrete through sweat that give other people
subtle messages about us.
One of these pheromones secreted in armpit
sweat is called 5 alpha-androstenol and is
thought to be linked to menstrual synchrony.
So while it’s possible that smelling 5 alpha-androstenol
affects women’s cycles leading them to sync,
it’s far more likely that all the other
things that are known affect a woman’s period
are actually what causes the appearance of
synchrony.
Because when you think about it, two women
menstruating for around five days a month
would probably end up overlapping at some
point.
So, ladies, have you ever found yourself seemingly
syncing with a roommate or close friend?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
find me and let me know directly on Twitter
as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.